this is another problem that cortaggio
sent me and i like these problems a lot
because they seem fairly simple on the
surface and actually the solutions are
pretty simple but just the nature of the
lack of information they give it becomes
kind of hard to even get started with
these problems and i'll be frank this
problem i kind of stumbled around with
it for a couple of minutes and until i
finally realized what what they were
asking for or how to solve for it so in
this problem we have bev and she takes a
train a train home at four o'clock
she arrives at the station at six
o'clock
every day driving at the same rate her
husband meets her at the station
fair enough one day she takes the train
an hour early and arrives at five her
husband leaves home to meet her at the
same usual time
at the same usual time husband leaves
home to meet her at the usual time
so maybe an interesting thing is to
think about when does the husband
normally
leave
so let's say that this is a normal
scenario i'll do that in green at six
o'clock she arrives
right we got there she arrives at the
station at six o'clock i don't know if
this four o'clock is useful yet
and the husband he got he gets there
right when she gets there
so he traveled
he gets there and i don't know if i'm
maybe i should draw a
a a more pot well let me just draw it
this way i think this is this is how my
brain kind of handles it
so
he gets there
and when did he have to leave what was
his time so let's say it takes him t
minutes to get there
whatever t is given in so if he gets
there at six o'clock that means he left
at six o'clock minus t if t is 30
minutes it would be 5 30 if t is one
hour it would be it would be five
o'clock so
leaves
at
six o'clock
minus t
and t whatever units t happens to be
then he picks her up and then what does
he do he goes back home right
all right he goes back home
let me do that with the other the
skinnier line
he goes back home
same distance
and we assume that the car just turns
around immediately and that there is no
time devoted to picking her up she just
kind of jumps on the cars he spins
around
so should take him the same amount of
time right tea so when does he arrive
back at home so if it took him he left t
minutes before six o'clock and got there
so when does he get back what's going to
take him 10 minutes to get back so he's
going to arrive
arrive at six o'clock
plus t
and so what was the total amount of time
that he traveled and this is almost
superficially easy
well if you six o'clock plus t minus six
o'clock minus t the difference in time
is just two t he traveled a distance of
or a total time of 2t minutes and that's
almost obvious if it takes him 10
minutes to go and team us to come back
he traveled 10 minutes
fair enough now what happens on this day
it says that he leaves her husband
leaves home to meet her at the usual
time so once again
he is going to leave
he leaves i'll do me do this in red he
leaves
at six
o'clock minus
t
right
and then
she arrived early so she's going to be
walking back so there's going to be some
smaller time that it takes her him to
reach her so let's just leave that
unlabeled right now
so if i have a line here
so he's going to travel a shorter
distance and of course it's going to
take him less time
because she started walking right that's
what the problem tells us
right her she this today she arrives at
five o'clock and she begins to walk home
so she's going to make some distance up
so he's not going to have to travel
quite as far
and then he whatever time that was he
goes back the other way
goes back the other way it's going to be
the same amount of time
it's the same amount of time
and what does it tell us
he meets her on the way and then they
arrive home 20 minutes early so normally
they arrive at six o'clock
plus t right that's normal so today
they're going to arrive 20 minutes early
so they're going to arrive at
you could say 6 o'clock
6 o'clock
plus t that's just that minus 20 minutes
right they're going to arrive 20 minutes
early so what's the total amount of time
that he would have traveled on that day
the total amount of time
well he essentially
travels 20 minutes less than he does on
a normal day right he leaves at the same
time and he gets 20 minutes early and if
you take the difference between 6 plus t
minus 20 and 6 minus t you're going to
get 2t
minus 20. and that's almost i probably
didn't even have to draw all of this you
could just say well you know on a
regular day it takes him to if t is the
amount of time it normally takes him to
go to the station on a normal day he
travels 20 minutes today he leaves at
the same time gets 20 minutes early so
he he travels 2t minus 20 minutes
fair enough now what does that tell us
well how long did it take him to to get
to her how long did did this take her
well to go to pick her up takes the same
amount of time as to come back so he
must have taken half of this time to go
and half of this time to come back so it
must have been t
minus 10 to go and then t minus 10 to
come back so it took him 10 minutes less
to reach her this time
so what time does he pick her up and
this is the key it took him so normally
when it takes him t minutes when it
takes some t-minutes he gets there at
six o'clock
this time she started walking because
she got there early so and he gets there
10 minutes he reaches her 10 minutes
earlier than he normally would have
reached her right t minus ten normally
he reaches her at six o'clock today he
reaches her ten minutes earlier
so he reaches her at five fifty
he reaches her at five fifty
now
how the question is
how many minutes did bev walk
remember she arrived an hour early and
arrives at five o'clock and then she
starts walking
she arrives at five
five o'clock and just starts walking and
when does he pick her up he picks her up
at 5 50. so she walked for 50 minutes
that's a neat problem because on some
level it's very easy but on a lot of
other levels they can give you all of
this other information that's not
necessary for example you don't have to
know that she leaves at four o'clock
that's actually probably the most
unnecessary piece of information but
everything else is kind of left abstract
but even though you can they're not
giving a lot of details you can actually
figure out how far she walked without
knowing how fast she walks or how fast
her husband drives or how far they are
from the train station or how far the
house is from the trains or any of that
you're still able to figure out how far
she walked anyway neat problem thanks
again to cortaggio